the media have to come up with some
strategy to scare you into believing the
authoritarians who are in charge of our
coveted policy so the latest point
they're using is the death of colin
powell
so yesterday there are a lot of
headlines that colin powell had died
after being fully vaccinated he had two
shots of the vaccine he had not gotten
his booster yet and then he had a
breakthrough case of covid and he died
and the initial headlines were all about
how colin powell had died of a coveted
breakthrough and what a disaster this
was
okay so the initial headlines were like
the vaccines don't work okay that's
nonsense he had multiple myeloma he was
severely immunocompromised he had
parkinson's and multiple myeloma okay so
if you have a severe
immunodeficiency and if you are elderly
as he was he was 84 years old
then if you get a breakthrough case i
mean if you get a cold you could die
from that
right people who are elderly and are
immunocompromised and are already sick
tend to die when they get sick
it doesn't matter whether it's a
breakthrough case of covet or whether
it's regular covet they just die at
higher rates but the media have to scare
you and it's not just about scaring you
if you're elderly they have to scare you
you personally somehow the media and
your authoritarians of covet they need
to come up with a rationale for why you
need to remain extremely worried hey now
what they're going to do is they'll
they'll say that states that are read
and have not been as worried are bad
states right florida's a bad state and
then they'll just forget about it when
everything is fine in florida so for
example right now in florida extremely
low transmission rates in fact the
transmission rates of covet in florida
right now which of course is the worst
state in america right it's ron death
santos and all that crap the
transmission rates in in florida right
now are half the transmission rates in
new york you know who predicted this
anyone with a brain because as we move
into winter which is really nice in
florida and people are outdoors in
florida and as we move into winter in
the northeast where it's really gross
outside and people spend their time
indoors the virus will move around
indoors and that's not about coveted
policy that is just about reality when
you're indoors in close contact with
other people people get sick more often
it's why for a very long time people
always thought that the way you got my
dad still thinks this okay the way you
get a cold is because you're cold
outside
okay it's not because you're cold
outside it's because you go from the
cold outside to a place where you're in
close contact with other people
and then you breathe on them right that
is why people get sick during the winter
it's not because it is cold outside and
so it's cold and you went outside
without your mittens and then you got a
cold that's not how you got sick okay so
most viruses
are transmitted through close contact
with others close contact with others is
maximized when the weather is ugly
outside
okay but we have to pretend that
florida's super bad right okay so now
they've moved on from that because
florida's no longer a story because
florida the transmission rates are very
low so we're never going to hear about
that again and you never hear about it
when death santa's is doing fine you
only hear about it when death scientist
vaccinates most of the population and
then bad stuff happens anyway
that's when you have to blame death's
hand okay so
the new narrative is you need to
vaccinate so colon power doesn't die
okay this is the actual piece over at
the washington post today from philip
bump quote former secretary of state
colin powell died monday morning from
complications related to kelvin 19.
powell's disease resulted from a
breakthrough infection he was fully
vaccinated against covid but instead of
demonstrating that the vaccine isn't 100
effective in preventing death which was
known his death better serves to show
the need to tamp down on coronavirus
cases more broadly to help protect those
most at risk that group included powell
he was 84 years old when he died well
into the elderly age group that has most
been ravaged by the virus he'd also been
diagnosed with multiple myeloma which
can reduce the body's ability to fight
infections
last week the cdc released data showing
the effectiveness of vaccines in
curtailing new infections and deaths
from coronavirus in august it found
those who were vaccinated or six times
less likely to become infected and 11
times less likely to die of cover 19.
but the data also showed a disparity in
the death toll the incidence of covet
deaths among those 80 and over was
nearly as high as the incidents among
the unvaccinated age 50 to 64. which
again is not shocked that well i don't
know we're supposed to be surprised by
that when again people above the age of
80 die for lots of reasons because when
you're old you tend to die much more
easily than when you are younger
just the the simple math
says philip bump
older americans have always been at more
risk from code the effect of the virus
are clearly more pronounced with members
of that age group even when they are
vaccinated this should not be an impetus
to nihilism it is not the case that this
demonstrates that vaccines are futile or
not useful instead it's a reminder the
virus still poses a risk to the elderly
even when vaccinated and therefore that
the goal should be to tamp down on the
spread of the virus broadly if pell had
been at little risk of contracting the
virus because transmission rates were
low he would have been at almost zero
risk of dying from it but instead his
death comes at a time when more than 80
000 people a day are still contracting
the virus and more than 1 500 people a
day are dying from it about as many
people as we're dying in early april of
2020.
okay now here's the thing if you're
talking about reaching herd immunity we
have yet to see the country that has hit
quote unquote herd immunity to the point
where there is no transmission of virus
the asymptomatic are transmitting the
virus so barring full-time masking of
everyone and 100 vaccination rates which
none of which is achievable
there will be cases where people who are
immunocompromised come into contact with
virus and then get sick and then die
because unfortunately that is just the
way the world works
when philip bump says we need to force
vaccinate cops so colin powell doesn't
die
i'm sorry but this is not the way we
treat literally
anthony fauci himself the great god of
covid anthony fauci has said we have
eradicated to date one disease on planet
earth
the notion that you're going to be able
to eradicate a disease that is currently
circulating in literally millions of
people around the globe
and ensure that everybody who's
immunocompromised is is fully safe
without any protections
that's kind of wild
by the way should you be that worried
about a coveted breakthrough killing you
the answer is no the statistical proof
on this is pretty obvious there have
been 187 million people in the country
been fully vaccinated of those 187
million people about 7 200 have died and
about 85 of those deaths were people
over 65 and most of those people had
conditions that compromised their immune
systems apparently this is according to
politico
and so i'm not sure what you think the
purpose of yelling at people is but
apparently the purpose of yelling at
people is to just intimidate you into
silence
right that's the goal now is any of this
really effective like everybody who
wants to get vaccinated has now been
vaccinated
and the vaccines provide incredible
protection
can we move on at any point here
or is the authoritarianism the point
again i think this is a psychological
problem in half the country right now i
think that a huge number of people on a
financial level on a personal level on a
health level have decided that all risk
is worthy of avoidance
and that in order to mitigate the risk
we have to have somebody who knows
better an expert who crams down on your
neighbors what you can't cram down on
your neighbors yourself
the best way to mitigate risk is to make
sure that your neighbors are controlled
and so you got a media invested in that
ideology you have a government invested
in that ideology there's only one
problem none of it works and in fact you
have unforeseen risks like for example
the risk of crime that goes up when you
fire a bunch of cops
or the risks that the economy dies when
you tell everybody that they are unsafe
when they go back to work
there are a bunch of actual risks that
materialize the moment you say that you
have quashed all risk
the titanic is the same the safest ship
afloat up until the moment it rams
directly into an iceberg
the thing here is that the iceberg is
completely foreseeable i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the ben shapiro
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button so you stay up to date
with all our future content